do you feel trapped in a broken economic
model a model that's trashing the living
world and threatens the lives of our
descendants a model that excludes
billions of people while making a
handful unimaginably rich that sources
into winners and losers and then blames
the losers for their misfortune
welcome to neoliberalism the zombie
doctrine that never seems to die however
comprehensively it is discredited now
you might have imagined that the
financial crisis of 2008 would have led
to the collapse of neoliberalism after
all it exposed its central features
which were deregulating business and
finance are tearing down public
protections throwing us into extreme
competition with each other as well just
a little bit flawed and intellectually
it did collapse but still it dominates
our lives why well I believe the answer
is that we have not yet produced a new
story with which to replace it stories
are the means by which we navigate the
world they allow us to interpret its
complex and contradictory signals when
we want to make sense of something the
sense we seek is not scientific sense
but narrative fidelity does what we are
hearing reflect the way that we expect
humans and the world to behave does it
hang together does it progress as a
story should progress now we are
creatures of narrative and a string of
facts and figures however important
facts and figures are and you know I'm
an empiricist I believe
even facts and figures but those facts
and figures have no power to displace a
persuasive story the only thing that can
replace a story is a story you cannot
take away someone's story without giving
them a new one and it's not just stories
in general that we are attuned to but
particular narrative structures there
are a number of basic plots that we use
again and again and in politics there is
one basic plot which turns out to be
tremendously powerful and I call this
the restoration story it goes as follows
disorder afflicts the land caused by
powerful and nefarious forces working
against the interests of humanity but
the hero will revolt against this
disorder fight those powerful forces
against the odds overthrow them and
restore harmony to the land you've heard
this story before it's the Bible story
it's the Harry Potter story it's the
Lord of the Rings story
it's the Narnia story but it's also the
story that has accompanied almost every
political and religious transformation
going back millennia in fact we could go
as far as to say that without a powerful
new restoration story a political and
religious transformation might not be
able to happen
it's that important after they say faire
economics triggered the Great Depression
john maynard keynes sat down to write a
new economics and what he did was to
tell a restoration story and it went
something like this disorder afflicts
the land
caused by the powerful and nefarious
forces of the economic elite which have
captured the world's wealth but the hero
of the story
the enabling state supporting by
supported by working-class and
middle-class people will contest that
disorder will fight those powerful
forces by redistributing wealth and
through spending public money on public
goods will generate income and jobs
restoring harmony to the land now like
all good restoration stories this one
resonated across the political spectrum
Democrats and Republicans labor and
conservatives left and right all became
broadly Keynesian then when Keynesianism
ran into trouble in the 1970s the
neoliberals people like Friedrich Hayek
and Milton Friedman came forward with
their new restoration story and it went
something like this you'll never guess
what's coming disorder afflicts the
lehand
caused by the powerful and nefarious
forces of the over-mighty state whose
collectivizing tendencies crush freedom
and individualism and opportunity but
the hero of the story the entrepreneur
will fight those powerful forces wrong
back the state and through creating
wealth and opportunity restore harmony
to the land and that story also
resonated across the political spectrum
Republicans and Democrats conservatives
and labour they all became broadly
neoliberal opposite stories with an
identical narrative structure then in
2008 the neoliberal story fell apart and
its opponents came forward with
nothing no new restoration story the
best they had to offer was the
watered-down neoliberalism or a
microwaved Keynesianism and that is why
we're stuck without that news story we
are stuck with the old failed story that
keeps on failing despair is the state we
fall into when our imagination fails
when we have no story that explains the
present and describes the future hope
evaporates political failure is at heart
a failure of imagination without a
restoration story that can tell us where
we need to go nothing is going to change
but with such a restoration story almost
everything can change the story we need
to tell is a story which will appeal to
as wide a range of people as possible
crossing political fault lines it should
resonate with deep needs and desires it
should be simple and intelligible and it
should be grounded in reality now I
admit that all this sounds like a bit of
a tall order
but I believe that in Western nations
there is actually a story like this
waiting to be told over the past few
years there's been a fascinating
convergence of findings in several
different Sciences in psychology and
anthropology in neuroscience in
evolutionary biology and they all tell
us something pretty amazing that human
beings have got this massive capacity
for altruism sure we all have a bit of
selfishness and greed inside us but in
most people those are not our dominant
values and we also turn out to be the
supreme co-operators we survive the
African savannas despite being weaker
and slower than
predators and most of our prey by an
amazing ability to engage in mutual aid
and that urge to cooperate has been
hardwired into our minds through natural
selection these are the central crucial
facts about humankind our amazing
altruism and cooperation but something
has gone horribly wrong disorder
afflicts the land our good nature has
been thwarted by several forces but I
think the most powerful of them is the
dominant political narrative of our
times which tells us that we should live
in extreme individualism and competition
with each other it pushes us to fight
each other to fear and mistrust each
other it atomizes society weakens the
social bonds that make our lives worth
living and into that vacuum grow these
violent intolerant forces we are a
society of altruists but we are governed
by Psychopaths
but it doesn't have to be like this it
really doesn't because we have this
incredible capacity for togetherness and
belonging and by invoking that capacity
we can recover those amazing components
of our humanity our altruism and
cooperation where there is atomization
we can build a thriving civic life with
a rich participate ori culture where we
find ourselves crushed between market
and state we can build an economics that
respects both people and planet and we
can create this economics around that
great neglected sphere the Commons the
Commons is neither market nor state
capitalism nor communism but it consists
of three main elements a particular
resource a particular community that
manages that resource and the rules and
negotiations the community develops to
manage it think of community broadband
or community energy cooperatives or the
shared land for growing fruit and
vegetables that in Britain we call
allotments a commons can't be sold it
can't be given away and its benefits are
shared equally among the members of the
community where we have been ignored and
exploited we can revive our politics we
can recover democracy from the people
who have captured it we can use new
rules and methods of Elections to ensure
that financial power never Trump's
democratic power again
representative democracy should be
tempered by participate Ori democracy so
that we can refine our political choices
and that choice should be exercised as
much as possible at the local level if
something can be decided locally it
shouldn't be determined nationally and I
call this the politics of belonging now
I think this has got the potential to
appeal across quite a wide range of
people and the reason for this is that
among the very few values that both left
and right share are belonging and
community and we might mean slightly
different things by them but at least we
start with some language in common in
fact you could see a lot of politics as
being a search for belonging even
fascists seek community albeit a
frighteningly homogeneous community
where everyone looks the same and wears
the same uniform chance the same slogans
what we need to create is a community
based on bridging networks not bonding
networks now a bonding network brings
together people from a homogenous group
whereas a bridging network brings
together people from different groups
and my belief is that if we create
sufficiently rich and vibrant bridging
communities we can thwart the urge for
people to burrow into the security of a
homogenous bonding community defending
themselves against the other so in
summary our new story could go something
like this disorder afflicts the lehand
caused by the powerful and nefarious
forces of people who say there's no such
thing as society who tell us that our
highest purpose in life is to fight like
stray dogs over a dustbin but the heroes
of the story us we're revolt against
this disorder we will fight those
nefarious forces by
building rich engaging inclusive and
generous communities and in doing so we
will restore harmony to the land
now whether or not you feel this is the
right story I hope you'll agree that we
need one
we need a new restoration story which is
going to guide us out of the mess we're
in which tells us why we're in the mess
and tells us how to get out of that mess
and that story if we tell it right will
infect the minds of people across the
political spectrum our task is to tell
the story that lights the path to a
better world thank you
[Applause]